Вониклюнули нарекламні оголошенняв румунських ЗМІ.
Німеччина шукає працівниківдлям’ясноїпромисловості.
Вони покинули батьківщину в пошуках кращого життя. Але дуже швидко прийшло розчарування.
Найгіршим був робочий час. Мені довелося вставати о першій ночі, щоб їхати на роботу.
Посеред глибокого сну.Ідоводилося працювати до 17-18 години.
З нами поводяться, як з рабами.
Щодня треба носити тонни м’яса. Болить спина.
А в кінці місяця отримуєш лише 800 євро.
Іноді хочеться просто плакати.
Обидвазалишилим’ясокомбінат через три місяці.
Влаштувалися укомпанії Marten в Гютерсло.
Тут вони сподіваються на кращі умови праці.
Але також й тому, що з 1 квітня м'ясній галузі у Німеччині не дозволяється використовувати працю тимчасових працівників.
Раніше іноземні робітники працювалина субпідрядників, деїм платили жалюгіднузарплатню.
Однак тепер профспілки та роботодавці не можуть домовитися про колективний договір.
Представники працівників чинять тиск, закликаючи до попереджувальних страйків.
Інформацію про стан переговорів вони оприлюднюють трьома мовами -  румунською, польськоютаросійською.
Адже багатопрацівниківне розуміють німецької.
А трудові угоди, які вонипідписали,булинаписані німецькою.
І тому часто вони занадто пізноусвідомлюють, у що вляпалися.
Погані умови праці, погана заробітна плата.
Людиприїздятьзхибнимиуявленнямитастикаються з тим, що Німеччинанасправдіне є раєм.
Райських умов53-річний ГабріельТеодорескуі не чекав.Але хоча б справедливу оплату праці.
Чотири місяці майстер широкого профілю працював на будівництві у ФРН.
Щомісяця він зароблявлише 300євро.Надто мало, аби вижити.
Я повинен працювати. Яж не марносюдиприїхав.
Я хочу підтримати своюродинув Румунії.
Мій син повинен мати можливість вчитися. Це важко.
Скрута привелайого до Німеччини. Як і багатьох східних європейців.
Десятки тисячвиконуютьтут роботу, яку не хочуть робити німці. Особливоум’ясній промисловості.
У містечкуЕльдеу сільській частині Вестфалії живе багато румунів, які працюють на м’ясних або ковбасних заводах у цьому регіоні.
Вонивже два місяцічекають,абиїмвиплатилизарплатнюу повномуобсязі, розповідають ці чоловіки.
Через це вони не можуть пересилати гроші своїм сім'ямдоРумунії.
Ми так далеко від дому, сподівалися, що тут, у Німеччині, буде краще.
Якби ми знали, як тут насправді, то не приїхали б.
10 днів ми їли лише макарони з цукром.
Ми запитали про зарплату і нічого не отримали.Нам лише брешуть.
Повернімосядо попереджувального страйкубілякомпанії Marten у Гютерсло.
Поки одні страйкують, інші чекають початку своєї зміни на м’ясокомбінаті.
Включно зрумунами, які вже два роки працюють у Німеччині.
Доцього я працювалав Іспаніїбільше восьмироків.
Мій чоловік був удома в Румунії з дітьми.
Коли син закінчив школу, язабрала йогодо Німеччини, а згодом і мого чоловіка.
Тепер сім’я хоче залишитися разом, у Німеччині.Де профспілки не здаються і організовують подальші попереджувальністрайки.
Опір, докине будедосягнутоколективного договору.
Рано чи пізноексплуатація в м’ясній промисловостімає припинитися, переконані активісти.
У подібні історії зрабською експлуатацією та невиплатою обіцяногоу Німеччиністикалисяне разіукраїнці.
Пообіцяли, що збоїв не буде. А потім дивимося, що минає ще місяць, вже додому їхати. Грошей немає.
Почалися дзвінки наші на фірму, на всі можливі номери. А там просто відмовчувалися.
То казали, що будуть гроші. Потім відмовчувалися. Потім узагалі заблокували наші номери.
Ми зрозуміли, що сенсу немає. Поїхали додому.
Експерти радять, аби не потрапляти на гачок недобросовісних роботодавців або посередників, зважати на кілька базових речей.
Перше - ретельно перевіряти фірму-роботодавця ще до виїзду за кордон,
запитувати про неї через інтернет-форуми, наприклад, українців Німеччини у Фейсбуку.
Друге - шукати посередників з працевлаштування, яким за послуги платять роботодавці, а не самі шукачі роботи.
Третє і головне - у жодному разі не погоджуватися на нелегальне працевлаштування за кордоном.
Звертайте увагу на розмір обіцяної зарплатні.
Вона не може бути вищою, ніж те, що в середньому за ту ж роботу отримують німці.
У жодному разі не віддавайте паспорт під час подорожі або прийому на роботу.
І підписуйте контракти про працевлаштування лише тією мовою, яку розумієте.
Нині за кордоном працює, за різними оцінками, від півтора до 3 мільйонів українців.
Для багатьох з них робота за кордоном - байдуже, в яких умовах - чи не єдиний спосіб прогодувати свої родини.
Грошові перекази українських трудових мігрантів стали важливою статтею надходження валюти в країну.
У пандемічному 2020-му році, згідно зі звітом Національного банку України,
обсяг переказів трудових мігрантів в Українусклавпонад12 мільярдів доларів.